-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Jake Tapper.
I'm lucky enough to know
your wonderful wife, Jen.
I have heard you say that
the character in this film -
in this book, excuse me --
Margaret, is based on Jen.
How does she feel about that
if it is, in fact, true?
-Well, I mean, Margaret
is loosely based on Jen.
She's a very strong feminist
and the moral center
of the family
and obviously gorgeous
and flawless.
So, yeah.
I mean, I think she feels
pretty good about it.
-You have Margaret
have an interaction
with L. Ron Hubbard,
the founder of Scientology
Did you have any hesitatio
about that,
as this is a famously litigiou
group of people?
-[ Laughs ] I did.
I did. Absolutely.
But then, I thought,
"So I feel no compunction
about writing about the Kennedys
and Sinatra and everything
but I'm gonna be afraid
of L. Ron Hubbard's ghost?
I mean, so, you know,
I thought about it.
I mean, should I call it, like
the Church of Biology?
But then I'm like, "Why? Why?"
I'm writing about
everybody else that's real
but I'm gonna blink
with this one group?
And it's fiction. It's fiction
You know?
And just for the record
so the lawyers don't have to -
I don't have L. Ron Hubbar
kill anybody.
Just so everybody knows.
So everybody knows.
-Sounds like you're still
going to get a call.
Hey. I can't believe
we've never talked about this.
Some of your film work.
You've been on this show
over a dozen times.
This is a film
I love a great deal.
The Doug Liman film
"Edge of Tomorrow."
You have a cameo.
I want to show it real quick
and then hear how you enjoye
this bit of acting work.
Let's take a look.
-The only thing missing is you
-She killed hundreds of mimics
-She was able to kill
hundreds of mimics
on only her first day in combat.
Imagine an army
of Rita Vrataskis.
-So there you go.
Tom Cruise on your show.
How was he to work with, Jake?
-You know, they -- I didn'
even know he was in the movi
until, like, a day
before it came out.
They CGI'd him into my set
I didn't get to meet --
When Wolf --
Wolf did a cameo on,
I think, the most recent
"Mission: Impossible."
They flew him to London.
They put him up first-class.
He was in a scene.
He has photos of him
and Tom Cruise together.
But for me,
they just did a CGI thing.
I don't even think --
I don't even think
I got a dollar from that.
-[ Laughter ]
-I don't think I got --
By the way, it's a good --
it's a good movie.
And I am -- Is this becaus
of the Church of Scientology
that you brought that up?
-Yeah, yeah.
That's why he was like,
"This guy's gonna put
L. Ron Hubbard in a book.
I want no part of him."
-That's why he CGI'd it? Because
he knew that was gonna --
Because "Edge of Tomorrow,
he knows the future.
Okay. Makes sense.
-I always --
I thought Wolf Blitzer
was great in the
"Mission: Impossible" movies
[ Laughter ]
It bums me out.
My least favorite thing
about the "Mission: Impossible
movies is that
they don't just put --
I would so prefer
to see what Simon Pegg
looked like
in a Wolf Blitzer mask.
Instead of that move of, like,
it's clearly Wolf Blitzer,
and then he does this.
Just, like, make
the most hyper-realistic -
It would look so bad.
And that would be more fun
-It would look like when
Sudeikis would do Wolf Blitzer
When it looked and sounded
nothing like Wolf Blitzer.
-How dare you.
Sudeikis would take weeks!
If he was doing a Wolf Blitzer
he'd go away to his cabin.
-He went to Buffalo. I know.
-He would just wear headphones
-You know how he got it wrong?
You know how he got it --
First of all, I love Sudeikis,
so let me just say
that even though
I'm not a fan of his Blitzer
I'm a fan of everything else
he does.
But the beard --
This is really a costume
design and beard and makeup.
You never had the beard
shorn enough.
He has a very close shave.
He's assiduous
with the grooming.
And the Sudeikis Wolf,
it was too shaggy.
It was like -- Honestly,
it was like a Kenny Rogers
-Wolf -- is it true he shave
during commercials, right?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean,
he doesn't do it himself.
He has people.
-Right. He has a team.
By the way, I thought
you needed to be worried
about Scientologists
coming after you,
but when the "SNL"
beard department sees this
lock your doors.
Hey, um,
here's my last question.
Do you think, you know,
because you have a family...
where you are not
the first best-selling author.
Your daughter, Alice,
wrote a book.
Best-seller --
"Raise Your Hand."
Does she have any fear tha
you're going to overtake her
or does she just sort of scoff
at the fact that
you're second to the party
-[ Laughs ] I am the last
in the totem pole
of the Tapper family.
And I don't know
where you are in yours,
but, like, I am
underneath the dogs.
So, you know, Alice
isn't even looking down at me.
I mean, like, I'm --
That's like looking
at the Kansas City Royals.
-Sure. Sure.
-Last place.
She actually has an idea
for another one,
but the problem is she's 13 now,
so she's got other stuff
she wants to do, so --
-Right. It was very--
I mean, it just speaks
to her being ahead of the game
a little bit
that she wrote a book at a tim
when she was at the age
to have the focus for it.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, exactly.
"I'm going to do it now
when I'm 11
because I've got other stuff t
do as a teen and as an adult."
-Right. She'll work on
the movie adaptation
of "Raise Your Hand"
when she's 13.
She doesn't have time
to go write another book.
Hey, buddy, congratulations.
It's always a delight
to see you.
Hopefully next time you'll
be here in person with us.
-Absolutely. Absolutely.
-"The Devil May Dance"
is available
wherever books are sold,
but please support your loca
and independent bookstores